bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video di natale che quest'anno è
arrivato come gli altri anni il 25
puntualità estrema sea volta andati
ragazzi miei su omegle non facevo mi
gold ha veramente un anno e mezzo quindi
non vedo l'ora di iniziare ragazzi per
chi non lo sapesse un eagle e questo
sito che serve per incontrare le persone
che ti seguono quindi appare webcam con
loro e ci chat in live il mio regalo per
voi ragazzi e cercare di accontentare il
più possibile di voi che se non connessi
ad ogni gol perché ho scritto su
facebook che mi connettiamo ad ogni gol
dai cominciamo che dalla vita che non
faccio mio per incontrarmi bastava
scrivere buckingham palace e per poveri
su nelle tag
non chiedetevi perché e poi cliccare su
video diamo se riusciamo a trovare
qualcuno perfetto ciao ciao se la prima
hai vinto un premio una nuova cover che
quella fa veramente schifo nast che fa
tutto bene è tutto a posto stavi
studiando fisica mai capito che cercando
di soligo della leggermente meglio plata
è che chi ha incontrato dati pro rally
siano dei figli ho abbracciato una
ragazza è bella come tema ricordava sta
roba
ciao bella ciao ciao ti giuro ai capelli
migliori dei miei e di quelli di step di
messi insieme
secondo non sono una bella [ __ ] non devi
diventare rosso in questi casi facciamo
una foto bene tranquillo vai alla photo
io mi metto nelle solite posizioni belle
usa la mia bella pianta del piede e
valva giuro su dio
giuro veramente che non l'ho fatto
apposta giuro davvero la prima volta la
mia vita che mi capita di cascata e
diana non facciamo più le foto che sono
pericolose la fonte ma non mi sembra non
mi sembrava il caso sia dovuto vista la
scusa che abbia una che sta roba che non
si va in bagno su ogni gol luogo di
dentifricio niente falco che dite
individui come è andata questa
bellissima lavata di denti raccontaci la
tua esperienza va bene una passione mi
piace questo bagno questa questa
location fantastica ma da indurre quindi
donna aveva timido ma io ti auguro tanti
buoni e lavati i denti tanto buone feste
e buon natale con labbra certo ci
mancherebbe venga qua abbracci bagno e
non lo diciamo alla mamma
la [ __ ] porca fork è morta quella sì
ma stai calma mi sto sentendo male ero
solo capezzolo fa effetto a tutti con
alto di prima di vedere la fan art e
tesori red cro tesoro tu che si è
rimasta qua vai a prendere una tisana e
inietta gliela forte forte anche due
bellissima grazie a casa di satana
qualcosa di satana salve signor e prenda
più camomilla la prossima volta
supermercato che serve allora adesso
tutti chi stai calma 123 su e giù è suo
e giù a basse
calma calma stai da respirate servito
giurata un secondo omicidio
guardati ce l'ha con chi sto parlando
ciao ragazzo e mia moglie
state bene tutto a posto tipici
benissimo meglio di così non si può
parlando la tv via interrotto questo
momento tranquillo di romanticismo le
cazzeggiavo al cellulare io cazzeggiavo
sul cellulare love is in dr
ho trent'anni si no si vede che chi ne
ha un po pd membro dove da barbara seme
nei pressi n'attimo un po perché quali
babbo natale mi è caduta e non ha
trovato anche più quella quindi mi
aspetto che la setta aspetta aspetta
ecco qua guarda quanto sono swag anch'io
adesso ciò provoca lo smog che mi sale
cerco famiglia io cerco mama saddam
hussein bellissimi winnie the pooh
dietro complimenti per l'ottima scelta a
chi sta in foto dietro che non si vede
non si capisce michael jackson e michael
jackson quello tra lucio battisti da qua
pensate voga come sto messo o mio dio se
l'hai già scritto situ anche questo
l'hai già scritto io il tuo ragazzo ti
adoriamo ci ha certo ciao andrea
sciascia era fidanzata porca la [ __ ]
ai trovarne una singola edizione anche
chi chiama la famiglia cosa chiama la
famiglia e li sa cosa vuol dire la rana
aspetta che so fino a dopodomani c'è
tanta gente aspetta le richieste qua e
non è che va bene natale però eccolo qua
il capezzoli today
mi piace la mia stessa maglietta zia per
la grande inchiesta una foto alla
maglietta a me hai pensato un attimo
grazie
la notte sarà casa mia coste luci qua
che mi spara flash en in faccia fa un
caldo che non ha idea peggio d'estate ci
aiuta anche lui altro passo velo ti
prego da va beh è troppo cucciolo è
spuntata una mano tra l'altro proprio
ovvio che se mi sotto sumiko sono laici
aspetta rapporti proprio ti prego
ok l'anno scorso sono stato due ore tre
ore a cercarti e non mi si uscito da
vero adesso cinque minuti cinque minuti
teme possa andare bene come ha supposto
carissimo ci sentiamo è stato un piacere
buona italia abbonarono anche gli fate
scappare i giorni è sempre meglio il
telefono già pronta lei già tirato fuori
l'arma è pure natale guarda ciampi e
capelli tanti auguri tanti auguri anche
a te cara fi concorrenza i miei capelli
zia ma soprattutto a questo mercato noi
a qualcuno sono io
erano questi guarda che lascio i capelli
ordinati del solito herat è invece come
scommesse giustino è tutto a posto
la guarda e non va bene va bene forse
hai vinto anche il mio cane questo cane
non votarle un cane era mamma e mia
mamma con abbiano capito solo il caso ha
girato c'è una persona
grazie mille guardi lo anche a tua mamma
e al cane che si è girato ascoltare
questa black salverà ritirato fuori la
mado minchia come sono venuto meglio del
solito è la bellissima cazzo uguale so
come mi chiamo per ballo pallido è la
vada questa questo talento zio lo so
fare spetta come fai a fare questa cosa
cazzo amici sono allenato ero vedo
perché non sono anche perche tutta na
parla parla parla di grave se richieste
modica pezzo arriva una serissima caffè
[Musica]
se ce l'hai ciao palese in growl garber
grazie anche detto ciò fosse registrato
sinceramente unità ogni tanto succede
che spunta quello giusto purtroppo cioè
il microfono da prova prevista
intervista l'uomo fa mi l'intervista
buonasera siamo con come ti chiami
giovanni grazie di questa bella
intervista quanti anni hai e guanti bene
dai carissimo 40 cinesi a fare la tua
certo ci mancherebbe altro e riguarda
xvi è una conversazione piena piena
piena piena piena di qualità proprio non
poche volte nuovo di significato
soprattutto è va bene non è che puzzo
addirittura si è la madonna vabbè vabbè
ragazzi allora direi che possono
includere qui per oggi l'episodio di
ogni gol ma sarà un altro anno prima io
possa farne un altro da quando ho
iniziato a fare lo youtuber home eagle è
forse la cosa che amo di più registrare
perché anche quando finisco di
registrare mi viene da continuare a
provare a vedere se c'è gente sa cosa
fantastica perché mi sono messo nel
letto
siccome a casa mia fa caldo l'ho detto
anche nel video perché ci sono sti cosi
e vabbè riscaldano tutta l'area io dormo
in mutande anche se pieno inverno io
dormo in mutande per curiosità volevo
controllare se suo amico c'era ancora
qualcuno connesso no sono entrato ho
bloccato la webcam in modo tale che non
si accendesse e ho guardato se c'era
qualcuno si è connesso un mio fan smigol
non mi si accende per sbaglio la webcam
non so per quale cazzo di motivo il
computer l'ho preso e non fatto volare
in cucina speriamo che quel cristiano lo
stesso registrando con la merda lì
perché sennò siamo tutti nella no io
sono nella merda voi non centrate un
cazzo mi farò regalare un climatizzatore
per natale quindi ragazzi spero che i
video vi sia piaciuto a cose più
l'argomento è un mi piace io vi auguro
buon natale a tutti felice anno nuovo
preparato i ragazzi per questi giorni
usciranno un miliardo e mezzo di altri
video speciali in questo quadro solo il
primo e quindi ragazzi come solito il
video che ci lascia un commento è un mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e
cavani descrizione cerchi ti scateni ci
picchiavano proseguito è da ragazzi
che cazzo